hey i'm alvin and today i'll be teaching
you how to make my loaded scalloped
potato dough
this recipe kind of came about when it
was during the holidays and everybody
loves scalloped potatoes i think it's
one of the few dishes where if you bring
it to a party you can guarantee by the
time that you leave that plate is going
to be empty down to the last cheese bit
so during that time of the holidays i
was obsessed with using utensils and
pots and pans and different things to
make really cool shapes out of other
foods that we love and know one of the
tools that i think is super super
underrated is a stainless steel mixing
bowl because if you get the right kind
of stainless steel mixing bowl these are
actually oven safe you have this amazing
hemisphere baking pan i was like that's
really really cool like maybe i could
use this for something
the idea of scalp potatoes is that you
slice potatoes very thinly very
uniformly
you have like a bechamel sauce you have
some cream you have some pepper it's
really really delicious
i've never done this before it was kind
of scary because i didn't want to mess
it up and waste a lot of food the thing
was for this video i was carefully
arranging potato slices so neatly that
it took me forever to actually assemble
it i would like place a slice and make
sure i had the right slice that would go
next to it and cutting it was a pain so
this dish does take a little bit of time
to assemble but i think it comes out
with a beautiful result
[Music]
and you try to make sure that you layer
it in an even way that when it cooks
it's these nice little layers of
potatoes i also liked how loaded baked
potatoes they had bacon they have cheese
they have green onion so i was like okay
i want to incorporate flavor into this
gala potato dish so i would alternate
layers of like potato and cheddar cheese
and bacon and more potato and then
chives or green onions and other kinds
of cheese until basically like building
layers and layers and layers of flavor
[Music]
my hope is that by the time the cheese
melts it would actually serve as a glue
to keep the whole thing together so that
when you flipped it over it wouldn't
fall apart so that's also why there's
that much cheese in there and cheese and
potatoes holidays nobody's gonna
complain why you have that much cheese
in there but if you're a lactose
intolerant maybe not the right dish for
you i think the key here is really
really make sure you have a tight
overlapping seal with your potato slices
all around because that is essentially
your shield for the entire thing if that
breaks the whole thing's just gonna fall
apart
[Music]
it was pretty nerve-wracking the first
time i took it out of the oven because
you also have to let it cool for a very
long time because you take hot potatoes
cheese you flip it over it's going to go
everywhere the most nerve-wracking part
for me was when i finally inverted it
and like tapped it a bit and felt
something plop hard onto a sheet and i
was like this is it either half of it's
gonna be on the tray or the whole thing
is gonna be on the tray so either i'm
going home very happy or very sad so
when i unveiled it it was really really
cool because the potato had formed to
the edge of the mixing bowl making a
really nice dome shape and it really had
a nice fan pattern
after it's flipped onto a tray i bake it
in the oven for a little more just to
make sure that the edges can crisp up
potatoes look delicious and golden brown
and crispy
[Music]
and after you cut into it and you pull
it apart you can see all your work pay
off there's just so many layers in there
it would looked really really cool the
time i did it i thought it was really
fun and to kind of add in that sauce
that we didn't pour as much into i think
you can serve it with the sauce on the
side it's almost like a plated version
of scalloped potatoes i think it just is
a different visual way to showcase
scallop potatoes if you want to put in
the extra effort you can definitely
throw in other fillings as well just
make sure they're not too watery because
if they're too watery it'll cause
everything to be a little like watery
and we don't want watery potatoes it is
quite a interesting thing to pull off it
does take some time it's not the easiest
dish to make but i think the results are
well worth it so if you do make it
please let me know because that is an
achievement i think that deserves to be
seen so uh
happy potato week oh these lights are
bright
cool
[Music]
[Music]
you